تتر السيده حياه لشراء الخبز السياحي من
هذا المخبز بشكل يومي الرغيف الواحد يصل
سعره الى جنيه وربع فهي لا تملك بطاقه
تموينيه لشراء الخبز المدعم وتعاني من
ارتفاع اسعار الخبز الذي يمثل السمه
المشتركه لجميع وجبات الاسره كويس
ده يبقى افضل لي طبعا بافضلي واجي اخذ
جوده عيشته بقى كويسه برده لاني بطائق
التموين ليهم مستوى ثاني في جوده العيش مش
زينا اللي احنا ما عندناش بطاير هذا
الواقع تعاني منه ملايين الاسر وفي محاوله
للتخفيف من حده الازمه اعلن وزير التموين
عن البدء التجريبي لتدشيني منظومه جديده
تتيح للمواطنين الحصول على رغيف الخبز
المدعم بيساعد يقترب من 75 قرشا الاليه
الجديده سيتم تطبيقها عن طريق شحن
للبطاقات الذكيه التي يتم استخراجها من
قبل هيئه البريد كارت ممتاز وهيخدم الناس
كثير انا بدل ما باروح اجيب الرغيف
السياحي 40 جرام ب 100 جنيه هو هيديني 90
جرام ب 75 ده خطوه ايجابيه من الحكومه
طبعا ان هي تعمل الكابتن الذهبي للجماعه
اللي هم ما لهمش بطائق تموين عشان الناس
دي بصراحه اصبحت فريسه الاصحاب المخابز
الخاصه جدير بالذكر ان مصر وقعت مؤخرا على
اتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي بقيمه ثلاثه
مليارات دولار بعض البنود تركز على ضروره
تقديس الدعم الحكوميه على الكثير من السلع
والخدمات رئيس الوزراء المصريه اعادت
تاكيد انه لن يتم المساسه باسعار الخبز
المدعم والذي يبلغ سعره خمسه قروش للرغيف
مواطنون رحبوا بهذا الاعلان الذي يحمي
الخبز من التضخم الذي وصل الى جميع السلع
يعني واحده معه خمس اطفال دلوقتي اللي معي
خمس اطفال ما بيكفينيش 30 جنيه عيش كل يوم
اجيب منين انا اصلا
التقييم لتجربه بطاقات هيئه البريد
وانعكاساتها على تامين الخبز باسعار
المخفضه لملايين الاسر ويبقى التحدي
الحكومي في النجاح في فرد رقابه على
الاسواق لضمان عدم التلاعب باسعار السلع
الغذائيه في ظل شكاوى متكرره من الشارع من
تبيعات موجات الغنائي غير المسبوقه احمد
عثمان العربيه القاهره